olá tudo isso aqui quem fala é o dark
seja muito bem-vindo gervais um vídeo e
o estrago já que convênio nos next é eu
perguntei porque nos netos se vocês
gostariam que eu fizesse um vídeo
mostrará que esse cara que vocês
respondeu nunca assim portanto que eu
vou fazer é olhem pra mim eu nunca ia
chutar
assim o do chapéu igual a roubar um
almoço na escola colabora o mesmo sua
rede cinemark no step into me que tá
frio algumas caras do que eu já conheço
outras não portanto vamos ter que fazer
o teste sou uma bruxa será a taxa é de
20 aqui já há até um nome que extingue o
efeito mês passado não falte não é que ó
ó dinheiro
tenho uma pergunta pra vocês é será que
o meu dedo cheira bem vamos ver se na
petrobras
a taxa é de r 27 em genebra
este é o que as meninas usam do ele
destacou a professora tem uma dúvida
professora olha 24 e se lembram disso
lembro de um [ __ ] e oi
olá pessoal estou fazer um vídeo nos
objetos mães inep está feito por um novo
feijão só pessoal ou tem história está
em a opção é parceirão foi um cão
o meu dono trata da lei
sugam com óculos o cargo porque é isto é
um sonho que aconteceu à minha nuca
não estou um pouco torta pessoal o oi
até que vai acontecer quando se o
pessoal não contem a ninguém eu tenho
crédito pra você a copa ia mexer no dedo
torto
paulo o som parece que a província é
minha história
ae sua linha do chocolate baton do
livreto berlim do pessoal e 2 quilates e
mail e foi o rei foi o pessoal vai ter
outra promoção fugir algumas mexem com a
agenda e suavizou e minha pele está a
usar né é um filtro pessoal e só o rei
da selva agora e que sabem qual é o
primeiro prato porção sorrir
a chamartín sentem um cigarro contém um
cigarro eu falo com ele
a bom gosto
oiço rango sabem o que é que eu era se
fosse um animal sabe sabe
sabem alguém sabe eu era um morango tem
hahahha a minha mulher o ter neném
olha os dentes do frame sofrerem pessoal
gosta eu também te amo
então é isso pessoal vamos ficar porque
os filhos para que vocês tenham gostado
não esqueçam só ali tinha 11 anos tem
jeito que o governo os nossos netos e
rígido também é isso que eu estou aqui
favorito fiquem bem e até a próxima